Halo is more than just a game the series
is a cultural Touchstone that has become
a pillar in the shooter genre so in
honor of the 15th anniversary of Halo 3
this month I wanted to focus on one of
the most influential Shooters of all
time these are 10 things you never knew
about Halo 3.
number 10 hear kitty kitty a certain
calico kitten pops up in both Halo and
Halo 3. in the original Halo a post on
the UNSC pillar of autumn bulletin board
States lost calico cat answers to Jonesy
Jonesy is still missing in Halo 3.
during the campaign mission Crow's Nest
you can find posters with the same
message this time with a helpful image
to identify the Calico Critter the
ripped up version of the sign can be
found in the trash in the barracks
section of the level Jonesy has made
their way across the stars in Halo but
this missing feline gets its name from
the curious cat in the movie Alien
foreign
number nine bomb Voyage every assault
bomb used during a game of assault in
Halo 2 3 reach contains a special
message for its Targets in Halo 3 there
are two messages depending on whether
you're the connection host if you are
the host the message will read hold on
to your butt and if you're not the
message will read thus I refute thee
hold on to your butt refers to Jurassic
Park when Samuel L Jackson flips the
power back on hold on to your butts and
thus I refute these some philosophical
in joke freaking nerds
number eight The Missing Link level
Sierra 117 has some native inhabitants
you can view if you know where to look
on the right side of the river during
the chapter charlie foxtrot if you look
into the group of trees you'll find a
silhouette of a tiny caveman sitting in
one of them in the narrow Canyon where
sergeant major Johnson details that his
Pelican was shot down you can find an
outcropping of rocks on the left side of
the canyon where the actual path of the
level turns towards the right if you
jump up to the higher level of the rocks
and Crouch along the path you'll find a
family of cavemen and one lone caveman
is found on the right side of the bridge
at the end of the level where the two
large rocks meet
now the Easter egg goes even deeper the
faces of the cavemen belong to
co-creator of the Halo Universe Marcus
Leto this is an in-office joke at Bungie
called the gorillato which consisted of
photoshopping lato's face onto a female
gorilla
[Music]
number 7 Jason Jones Jason Jones the
co-founder of Bungie seems to appear all
over the Halo Universe and Halo 3 is no
exception during the missions the storm
and Floodgate there are missing person
Flyers all around for a missing person
Jason Jones if you're on the hunt he was
last seen in voy and new Mombasa wearing
khaki shorts and a dark baseball cap
Jones appears again in game but in a
much more relaxed state in the secret
room of the seventh terminal there's a
room with a horizontal energy beam and
an immense Abyss there is a little-known
secret room across the chasm on the left
side the easiest way to access this room
is to detach the camera in theater mode
and fly in you'll find a cutout of Jones
shirtless with his hands behind his head
number six man in the moon on the
multiplayer map standoff a face is
hidden on the moon it turns out that the
face is a picture of Chris Carney a
former Bungie employee from 2001 to
2015.
number five hippos in my Halo game
hippos have permeated the Halo Universe
sent it to deception in Halo Combat
Evolved a cartoon hippo can be found on
the shotgun shells in Halo 2 the same
image is on the walls of a building in
the headlong multiplayer map and in Halo
3 a small purple hippo is poking out of
a pile of trash on the multiplayer Map
Foundry
number four Marine versus password on
the level Crow's Nest at the end of the
first Corridor there's a marine just
trying to get some supplies but he
doesn't know his password while this
Easter egg is funny in its own right it
makes sense that it was written and
voiced by the creators and voice actors
in Red vs Blue the dialogue will also
change depending on what difficulty
setting you choose I won't play out each
clip because they're lengthy albeit
hilarious but here is each pairing
depending on the difficulty level for
easy and normal the Marine is voiced by
Jason Saldana who plays Tucker and the
voice behind the door is Matt hollom who
plays doc on heroic the Marine is
Gustavo cirola who plays Simmons and the
voice is Jeff Ramsey who plays Griff and
on legendary the Marine is Bernie Burns
who plays church and the voice is Joel
Heyman who plays caboose
number three yeah suck it Franc inside
the freezer on the DLC map Longshore a
message reads suck it Franc this is a
reference to francs a fish nugget brand
advertised in Mombasa the Easter egg is
also contact specific changing on
particular dates on Christmas Day a
seventh column emblem appears on Bungie
day the sign reads seven seven on
Halloween a skull on July 4th the sign
reads home of the free on Cinco de Mayo
the sign reads root beer at Bob's on New
Year's Day the sign reads flash freeze
this on Earth Day an image of Frank with
the word save me eat beef and on
Veterans Day a Spartan giving a rock on
gesture
number two ears of the devil across Halo
2 and 3 backward audio messages reveal
some hidden secrets in the Halo 3
soundtrack at the 45 second Mark of the
track Black Tower there are some hidden
foreboding lines if you reverse the
track
[Music]
[Music]
these messages are an homage to the poem
The Hollow Men by T.S Eliot the first
stance of the song refers to lines 20 to
23. in death's dream Kingdom these do
not appear there the eyes are sunlight
on a broken column the second stanza
refers to lines 47-49 walking alone at
the hour when we are trembling with
tenderness lips that would kiss form
prayers to Broken Stone although this
could just be Bungie's fandom of T.S
Eliot it is also an homage to the Halo 3
E3 trailer in 2006. in the trailer
Cortana States this the way the world
ends in the last stanza of the Holloman
goes as follows this is the way the
world ends this is the way the world
ends this is the way the world ends not
with the bang
but a whimper
number one life's a beach and we're just
playing in the sandbox on the
multiplayer map sandbox you can access a
secret area of the map in a mysterious
warning sign using the out of Sky bubble
glitch when you load up the level
sandbox and Forge enter edit mode and
fly to the teleporter that takes you
outside the Skybox from there get to the
invisible wall surrounding the Skybox
select the receiver node from your
inventory and hold it to fly through the
invisible wall you can get super close
to the guardian Tower left of the
Setting Sun the closer you get you
should be able to make out a warning
sign this is effectively the splatter
metal with a few tweaks if you get too
close to the guardian Tower you will hit
a kill wall and all I can say is you
were warned important to note this kill
wall only activates when you get close
to that specific Guardian Tower the rest
let you climb them
or maybe not
[Music]
Halo especially the bungee made entries
are regarded as some of the most
prestigious Shooters in video games they
tell a compelling and highly praised
story and offer a plethora of
multiplayer options that are bar none in
the industry I love that the devs were
able to add some ridiculous secrets and
Easter eggs in Halo 3. man all I want to
do now is get some like crazy Gravity
Hammer battles on Narrows or any of
those smaller Maps those are the best
anyways catch me on Twitter at sewer
review and for everything else video
games keep it here at GameSpot